Hey guys, this is Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, and this is part three of making meaning in the modern world, or fixing the modern soul, a series on what psychology is going to have to address if it's going to change to keep pace with the world and its problems that are new. Some of them are old or have a symbolic root that is older, but some of them are entirely modern. And one of the things that we talked about in the first episode was that the world was feeling like this kind of simulacra or copy without an original, which is a paradox. That you're looking around and you're saying everything feels like it doesn't work or like it's breaking or that these things don't really point back to the symbols that they used to point back to or or serve the purpose that they used to you know things like government
大家好，我是Taproot Therapy Collective播客的Joel。这是“在现代世界中寻找意义”或“修复现代灵魂”系列的第三部分。该系列探讨了心理学若想与时俱进，解决当今世界的新问题，必须做出哪些改变。有些问题是旧有的，或者有着更古老的象征根源，但有些则是全新的现代问题。我们在第一集中谈到的一点是，世界感觉就像是一种拟像，或者说没有原件的复制品，这本身就是一个悖论。你环顾四周，会觉得一切都行不通，或者正在崩塌，又或者这些事物不再指向它们曾经指向的象征，也不再发挥它们曾经的作用，比如政府。
that it doesn't even feel like you know people are even trying to lie well or things like social media and our socialization that we're doing socialization but we're because that's been you know changed through digital digital technology through that being curated through an algorithm it feels hyper real but it also feels not real you know and because we're so obsessed with objectivity with logic and reason um we're looking around and objectively there's nothing wrong with the world. Yet I feel crazy in a subjective way, in a subjective space. So it must just be me. And I was saying, I think everyone feels like that. At least I do.
甚至感觉人们连谎都懒得撒了，或者像社交媒体和我们的社交方式，虽然我们在进行社交，但因为这一切都通过数字技术、通过算法进行了筛选，它感觉超真实，但又感觉不真实。因为我们太执着于客观性、逻辑和理性，我们环顾四周，客观上觉得世界没什么问题。然而，在主观层面、在主观空间里，我却感到自己快疯了。所以一定是我自己的问题。但我当时说，我觉得每个人都有这种感觉。至少我是这样。
And all of the people that I talk to all day long and the therapists that I talk to about the people they talk to all day long, we feel alone with this and we're not alone with it. So what do we do with it? How does, how does psychology start to address that, you know, feeling? And I had talked about how in the first episode, you know, Friedrich Nietzsche saw the work of philosophers that claimed to be hyperlogical and rational and had just pulled out some point of objective truth from the universe through just reason and science and empiricism, he saw that they were sort of telling on themselves, that they were insane, that they were
我整天交谈的所有人，以及我与治疗师们讨论他们整天接触的来访者时，我们都感到在这种孤独中并不孤单。那么我们该怎么办？心理学如何开始解决这种感觉？我在第一集中谈到，弗里德里希·尼采曾观察到，那些声称自己超逻辑、超理性的哲学家们，仅仅通过理性、科学和经验主义就从宇宙中提取出某种客观真理，他认为他们实际上是在暴露自己，他们是疯狂的，他们是
they were clinging to this hyper logical rational worldview in a way that you know people like Descartes did then and a lot of people you know maybe like Jordan Peterson do now where they pretend these incredibly subjective beliefs are just purely logical, scientific endeavors that, you know, just given to them by the objective truth and nature of the universe in a way that really, if you listen to them, they're kind of telling on themselves. And I was arguing, you know, that what we could do, what you can do when you're looking at psychology and the different schools of psychology, I would say that really most of my lifetime therapy has gone in a pretty bad direction. Now clinical psychology is going in some interesting ones and academic psychology is still clinging to some pretty bad ones. I would like them to be more on the same page than they are, but it's not up to me.
他们以一种固执的方式坚持这种超逻辑的理性世界观，就像笛卡尔当年所做的那样，以及现在像乔丹·彼得森这样的人所做的那样。他们假装这些极其主观的信仰纯粹是逻辑性的、科学性的努力，仿佛是宇宙的客观真理和本质赋予了他们。如果你仔细听，会发现他们其实是在暴露自己。我当时主张，当你审视心理学及其不同流派时，我认为在我有生之年，治疗的发展方向相当糟糕。现在临床心理学正在走向一些有趣的方向，而学术心理学仍然固守着一些相当糟糕的观念。我希望它们能达成更多共识，但这不由我决定。
But really, you can do the same thing with models of therapy, because to me, what a model of therapy has to do is it has to define a sense of self. Like, who do you think we are? What are we? You know, one of the things that made Freud so revolutionary, I think one of the only things that has endured from Freud, mostly, is that the self is not one thing. It's not the center of our logical, our ego, or our whatever. It is these dynamic forces that sort of disagree and buff it up against each other. I think that conception is good. And I think losing that conception to move something towards something like cognitive behavioral therapy, or especially something like behavioral only, or, you know, ABA therapy is incredibly dangerous. And the reason for that is that therapy to me is a conversation between the self and the world.
但实际上，你可以用同样的方式对待治疗模型，因为对我来说，一个治疗模型必须定义一种自我感。比如，你认为我们是谁？我们是什么？我认为弗洛伊德之所以具有革命性，且他留下的东西中唯一经得起时间考验的，就是自我并非单一的东西。它不是我们逻辑、自我（ego）或任何东西的中心。它是那些相互冲突、相互碰撞的动态力量。我认为这个概念很好。而我认为为了转向认知行为疗法，或者特别是像纯行为疗法，或者应用行为分析（ABA）疗法，而放弃这个概念是极其危险的。原因在于，对我来说，治疗是自我与世界之间的一场对话。
It is a way that you see how this person conceives of themselves in an inward way and conceives of the world, you know, largely, sometimes unconsciously through implicit memory in this outward way. And you're helping that process work again. Maybe my expectations for how the world is supposed to enable me are wrong. Maybe my expectations for what I'm supposed to be are impossible. These are the conversations it has to have. And where you need to start is, what is the concept of self that that model of therapy has. And the reason that I say that something like behaviorism is so crazy is that its concept of the self is nothing. You know, you can critique the Jungians and say, well, if you're saying that to know the self is to know God and all this
这是一种让你观察一个人如何在内心构想自己，以及如何在外部（通常在很大程度上是通过隐性记忆无意识地）构想世界的方式。你是在帮助这个过程重新运作。也许我对世界应该如何支持我的期望是错误的。也许我对“我应该成为什么样的人”的期望是不可能的。这些就是必须进行的对话。你需要从该治疗模型对自我的概念开始。我之所以说像行为主义这样的东西很疯狂，是因为它的自我概念是虚无的。你可以批评荣格学派，说如果你认为认识自我就是认识上帝，以及所有这些
mystical language and that the self is uniquely used to the divine and we have to understand that the unconscious is really a reflection of our spiritual desires even if we're secular materialists we still have to engage with those you know uh projections of spirituality in order to understand something maybe you think that's too out there and woo woo um but i would hope that we would all be equally terrified of a model that says the self is not real it's not there. You are only other people's external impression of you gleaned from your behavior. And you are only the things that have happened to you and the reinforcements and conditioning that you get positively and negatively for us to reinforce your behavior. But we don't really care who you are, right? And this is so scary to me because something like ABA, you know, applied behavior analysis is used to treat children with autism largely, right? And,
神秘的语言，认为自我与神性有着独特的联系，我们必须理解无意识实际上是我们精神欲望的反映，即使我们是世俗唯物主义者，我们也必须参与这些精神层面的投射才能理解某些东西。也许你认为这太离谱、太玄乎了，但我希望我们所有人都会同样恐惧那种认为“自我不是真实的，它不存在”的模型。你只是别人对你的外部印象，是从你的行为中收集来的。你只是发生在你身上的事情，以及你为了强化行为而获得的积极或消极的强化和条件反射。但我们并不真正关心你是谁，对吧？这让我感到非常害怕，因为像ABA（应用行为分析）这样的东西，主要用于治疗自闭症儿童，对吧？而且，
you know, I get that autism is going to be hard and that's not my area of expertise. I see a lot of adults on the spectrum, but I don't really work with children, you know, is I get that that's going to be hard because you can't communicate with the child in a way that psychotherapy wants us to communicate with or any kind of therapy or education through talking. So behaviorism, I don't think is the answer to that question. I mean, the models of therapy that say that the self is just a collection of behavior, that you're all just people's external idea of you. And so let's throw the internal world away entirely, because we don't really care who you are. I mean, you're saying that because this person is neurodivergent, they don't have a soul, essentially. And that's, that's horrifying.
我知道自闭症会很困难，这不是我的专业领域。我见过很多谱系障碍的成年人，但我并不真正与儿童工作。我明白这会很困难，因为你无法以心理治疗所期望的方式，或者通过交谈进行任何形式的治疗或教育来与孩子沟通。所以我认为行为主义并不是那个问题的答案。我的意思是，那些认为自我只是行为集合、认为你只是别人对你的外部印象的治疗模型，是在说我们要完全抛弃内心世界，因为我们并不真正关心你是谁。我的意思是，你是在说因为这个人是神经多样性的，所以他们本质上没有灵魂。这太可怕了。
Or if they do, you know, have a psyche or soul or whatever, that's just irrelevant to the model of psychology that we're using to change their behavior. That's really a bad road. And I extrapolated that in the second part to say that we can use these same assumptions in psychotherapy to look at really broader assumptions in our world that are very bad and also equally horrifying. For example, coming back to something like ABA and behavioral therapy like shouldn't
或者即使他们有心灵或灵魂之类的东西，那也与我们用来改变他们行为的心理学模型无关。这真是一条糟糕的路。我在第二部分中推论说，我们可以在心理治疗中使用同样的假设，来审视我们世界中非常糟糕且同样令人恐惧的更广泛的假设。例如，回到像ABA和行为疗法这样的东西，难道不应该
all the models of therapy teach people that they are a self and that other people are selves in this world too that we have to interact with not just be conditioned to act like they know that but to actually understand that i'm a person and another person is a person it's not if i want to take your candy if i want to hit you it isn't that i'm gonna have someone another person is a person. If I want to take your candy, if I want to hit you, it isn't that I'm going to have someone flash a red card at me and then when they flash the red card at me, I'm going to have my candy taken away and I'm going to be put in the time corner or whatever the punishment is.
所有的治疗模型都应该教导人们，他们是一个自我，而世界上其他人也是自我，我们必须与他们互动，而不是仅仅被训练得表现得好像他们知道这一点，而是要真正理解“我是一个人，另一个人也是一个人”。如果我想拿走你的糖果，如果我想打你，这并不是说我要让某人向我挥舞红牌，然后当他们挥舞红牌时，我的糖果会被拿走，我会被关进禁闭角，或者无论惩罚是什么。
And so I just need to learn to not take your candy or hit you. It's that I need to learn that you are a person and that I am a person. And then when I hit you and take away your candy, you have an inward experience that I have to learn to reckon with, right? I have to learn to understand. If you're taking the self out of therapy and the way that behavioral therapy does, I don't know that you can call it psychology at that point i think it's a very reductivist form of anthropology i'll come back to children that are autistic or neurodivergent you know but you know we have a world that i get is geared towards outcomes and objective oriented models of expression and socialization that has been commercialized and transactionalized and production.
所以我只需要学会不拿你的糖果或不打你。我需要学会的是你是一个人，而我是一个人。当我打你并拿走你的糖果时，你有一种我必须学会去面对的内心体验，对吧？我必须学会去理解。如果你像行为疗法那样把自我从治疗中剔除，我不知道在那一点上你还能不能称之为心理学，我认为这是一种非常还原论的人类学。我会回到自闭症或神经多样性的儿童身上，但我们所处的世界，我明白它是以结果为导向的，是以客观为导向的表达和社交模式，它已经被商业化、交易化和生产化了。
And so when you say, you know, people who don't have the ability to engage with those modes of self objectively are just going to have the nature of self discounted entirely, I think that speaks to a lot of bigger issues with our world. And when you look at something like how Silicon Valley is right now, and I'm not a Luddite. I built computers for a living before I did this. I use large language models to program large chunks of our website. I use them to collate data. I use them to clean up spreadsheets. I use them so I can write an article in bullet points or turn a transcript from a podcast into an article and then clean it up. I think that they have a place. But the fundamental assumptions underneath Silicon Valley right now is that if you get enough processing power, if you get enough comp time, you can turn a computer
所以当你认为那些没有能力以客观方式参与这些自我模式的人，其自我的本质将被完全忽视时，我认为这反映了我们世界中许多更大的问题。当你看看硅谷现在的样子时——我不是卢德分子，我在做这个之前是靠制造电脑为生的。我使用大语言模型来编写我们网站的大部分代码。我用它们来整理数据。我用它们来清理电子表格。我用它们来写项目符号文章，或者把播客的文字记录变成文章，然后进行润色。我认为它们有一席之地。但硅谷目前的基本假设是，如果你有足够的处理能力，如果你有足够的计算时间，你就可以把一台电脑
into a person. And the only way that you get there, you know, this whole industry, our society is telling on itself in a way that we need to hear. The way that you get there is that you think that people can be turned into robots also. And that is very scary to me. So that's a summary of the stuff that we did in part one and two. And a lot of the questions, you know, that we've already got are things like, you know, how do I pick a therapist? You know, how do I, I would say put this profession on trial, right? Like, I'm sure there's a brain spotting therapist out there that's bad. I'm sure there's somebody who does a model of therapy that I like that isn't doing it well you know I've met some Jungian analysts that I think are pretty not right even though I like Jung I don't know that
变成一个人。而你达到这一点的唯一方式——整个行业、我们的社会正在以一种我们需要听到的方式暴露自己——你达到这一点的方式是，你认为人也可以被变成机器人。这让我感到非常害怕。这就是我们在第一部分和第二部分所做内容的总结。我们已经收到很多问题，比如“我该如何选择治疗师？”我会说，把这个职业送上审判台，对吧？肯定有糟糕的脑点疗法（Brainspotting）治疗师。肯定有人在做我喜欢的治疗模型，但做得并不好。我见过一些我认为不太对劲的荣格分析师，尽管我喜欢荣格，但我不知道
that's the best model of therapy for everybody but I would say you need to put these people on trial and say how do you conceive of the self do you think I have a soul what is the goal of therapy you know if I have something that I don't want to know that it's going to blow my life up to find out, but that's true, are you going to pull a punch? Are you going to help me figure that out? Those are things that you are able to ask a therapist. Those are things that you should be able to get an answer for before you pay a lot of money and spend a lot of time and potentially, you know, have someone do something that is damaging. Whereas just because it's not you, it doesn't make room for you. So my answer to how to pick a therapist, I think, is to look for people who engage with these things in their profile,
那是否是适合所有人的最佳治疗模型。但我会说，你需要把这些人送上审判台，问他们：“你如何构想自我？你认为我有灵魂吗？治疗的目标是什么？”如果你有什么不想知道的事情，而发现它会摧毁你的生活，但那是事实，你会手下留情吗？你会帮我弄清楚吗？这些是你能够问治疗师的问题。这些是你应该在支付大量金钱、花费大量时间并可能让某人做一些破坏性事情之前，能够得到答案的问题。仅仅因为那不是你，并不意味着它没有你的空间。所以我对如何选择治疗师的回答是，寻找那些在个人资料中、
in their writing. Are they a curious person? Are they doing a different kind of therapy now than they did a year ago? Because they're continuing to learn something, not to take continuing education, but to actually continue to educate themselves because they want to, you know, the same way that you would pick a friend. You're not going to be friends with your therapist. You shouldn't find one that you want to be friends with. But we do read people in a way that we do. We want to spend time with this person that when we go into a doctor's office or it's a medical service, I think a lot of times we act like, oh, I don't have the credentials. I don't have the ability. You absolutely do. Bring your humanity into therapy
在他们的文章中参与这些事情的人。他们是一个好奇的人吗？他们现在做的治疗是否与一年前不同？因为他们在持续学习，不是为了完成继续教育学分，而是为了真正继续教育自己，因为他们想这样做。就像你选择朋友一样。你不会和你的治疗师成为朋友。你不应该找一个你想成为朋友的人。但我们确实以某种方式解读人。我们想和这个人共度时光。当我们走进医生办公室或接受医疗服务时，我认为很多时候我们表现得好像“哦，我没有资质，我没有能力”。你绝对有。把你的仁慈带进治疗中，
and expect the therapist to bring their humanity into it as well. So, you know, implicit memory, I think we talked a little bit about how the history of self is, you know, I, I think, you know, the, the problem with this relationship between the self and the world is that we aren't logical, objective creatures as much as we pretend to be. We sort of, when we stop dreaming, we sort of go insane. When we, when we stop being able to be metaphorical, to have symbol, to have spirituality, to have purpose, it doesn't matter if we have enough to eat, you know, that there's a whole lot of, you know, yes, behavioral psychology experiments that go back a really long time, like the cloth monkey experiment and things like that, that tell us that we have a part of the
并期望治疗师也将他们的仁慈带入其中。所以，关于隐性记忆，我想我们谈到了一点，即自我的历史是……我认为自我与世界之间关系的麻烦在于，我们并不像我们假装的那样是逻辑、客观的生物。当我们停止做梦时，我们就会变得疯狂。当我们无法再进行隐喻、拥有象征、拥有灵性、拥有目标时，我们是否有足够的食物并不重要。有很多行为心理学实验可以追溯到很久以前，比如布猴实验等，它们告诉我们，我们大脑中有一个部分
brain that we have to feed, and it doesn't need, we don't feed it with food. And so the problem, we've talked about this relationship between self and world, but the issue is Freud called it the subconscious. Jung called it the unconscious. Newer research now calls it implicit memory. Some people say primary, secondary, and tertiary cognitive processes. But we are waking up to this idea that waltzed out of Vienna a very long time ago, that we actually aren't really in control of everything about ourselves and the way that we think we are. At least our egos not. That there are a million things happening in our brainstem all of the time.
我们必须喂养它，而我们不是用食物来喂养它。所以问题在于，我们谈到了自我与世界之间的这种关系，但问题是弗洛伊德称之为潜意识，荣格称之为无意识。现在的最新研究称之为隐性记忆。有些人称之为初级、次级和三级认知过程。但我们正在觉醒于很久以前从维也纳传出的这个想法，即我们实际上并没有像我们认为的那样控制关于我们自己和我们思维方式的一切。至少我们的自我（ego）没有。在大脑干中，每时每刻都有数百万件事情在发生。
And these things happening in the brainstem are so incredibly fast. You know, a lot of them are traumatic responses that are maladaptive, but we built them through intuition. That base of our brain is actually intuitive. When you clear the trauma, you're able to tell the difference between your trauma and your intuition. And that part of the brain, that subcortical brain, is teaching you how to access memory and act on that memory emotionally and somatically, physically, and then make these implicit assumptions that color your cognition. And so therapy has to address that. But a lot of people don't think that that's real. And then also, to go into those places is very vulnerable. And it creates a sense of shame, because shame comes from this place where my relationship to the world was wrong, myself was wrong. You know, that's essentially what
这些发生在大脑干中的事情速度极快。其中许多是适应不良的创伤反应，但我们是通过直觉建立它们的。我们大脑的那个基础实际上是直觉性的。当你清除创伤时，你就能够区分你的创伤和你的直觉。大脑的那个部分，即皮层下大脑，正在教你如何获取记忆，并在情感上、躯体上、身体上对该记忆采取行动，然后做出这些影响你认知的隐性假设。所以治疗必须解决这个问题。但很多人认为那不是真实的。而且，进入那些地方是非常脆弱的。它会产生一种羞耻感，因为羞耻感来自这样一个地方：我与世界的关系是错误的，我自己是错误的。你知道，这本质上就是
shame is saying. And that could be that an unrealistic expectation of I'm not allowed to fail. And you're reminding me of a time that I failed. And yet my worldview, my external view is that I'm not allowed to do this. Only other people do this. And so when my self knows that it failed, it doesn't fit into this conception of the world, and now there is shame. And yet, when you go back into a trauma response, there's lots of different kinds of memory. It may not be a conscious, you know, understanding like that. It may be an overwhelming somatic piece where your whole body thinks that it's dying. And even though the my intellect doesn't, the client is suffering in that moment if I push them back into that place where their implicit memory assumptions that are
羞耻感所表达的。这可能是一种不切实际的期望，即“我不允许失败”。你让我想起了一次我失败的经历。然而我的世界观，我的外部视角是，我不允许这样做。只有别人才这样做。所以当我的自我知道它失败了，它就不符合这种世界观，现在就有了羞耻感。然而，当你回到创伤反应时，有很多不同种类的记忆。它可能不是一种有意识的理解。它可能是一种压倒性的躯体体验，你的整个身体认为它正在死去。即使我的理智不这么认为，如果我把来访者推回那个地方，他们的隐性记忆假设是
being relived are, I cannot live through this, I need to die. You know, they may not think that consciously, but their whole body is hot. My chest feels like a black hole. It's cold. It's sucking. You know, those things are overwhelming, those trauma responses. And so the thing that psychology is rapidly trying to do is figure out how to change implicit memory. You know, academics are not quite on this yet because they're having a hard time
正在重温的，即“我无法活过这一关，我需要死”。他们可能不会有意识地那样想，但他们的整个身体是热的。我的胸口感觉像一个黑洞。它是冷的。它在吸吮。那些事情是压倒性的，那些创伤反应。所以心理学正在迅速尝试做的事情是弄清楚如何改变隐性记忆。学术界还没有完全跟上这一点，因为他们很难
as a mainstream of the profession. Some journals are better than others, but they're having a hard time even admitting that this somatic integrative medicine using the body and getting into implicit memory is the point of therapy. But what they're all trying to figure out now is how do we get in and change implicit memory
作为职业的主流。有些期刊比其他期刊好，但他们甚至很难承认这种使用身体并进入隐性记忆的躯体整合医学是治疗的重点。但他们现在都在努力弄清楚的是，我们如何进入并改变隐性记忆
and therapy quickly. And it's this kind of this idea like if you like sound design of signal to noise ratio if i amplify this signal so that my voice is louder because i didn't record it enough yes the signal gets louder but what also gets louder the noise all of the background element that's roaring and the ceiling fan and the little pops and clicks and the feedback hum because my wire didn't have you know the nugget on it to stop that from happening the the magnet that filters out you know interference or something so it's the signal to noise ratio is if we if we go into and make the the trauma response if we go into this place where we're saying let's go further into implicit memory let's go to moments where yourself didn't overlap with what your self-image is where you know that you remember a time of being what you didn't
以及治疗。这就像声音设计中信噪比的概念，如果我放大了信号，让我的声音更大，因为我录音时录得不够，是的，信号变大了，但什么也变大了？噪音。所有那些咆哮的背景元素、吊扇、微小的爆裂声和咔哒声，以及反馈嗡嗡声，因为我的线没有那个磁环来阻止这种情况发生，那个过滤干扰的磁铁。所以信噪比是，如果我们进入并使创伤反应——如果我们进入这个地方，我们说“让我们更深入地进入隐性记忆，让我们去到那些你的自我与你的自我形象不重叠的时刻”，你知道，你记得一段你不想成为的样子，你觉得你无法活过那段时光，那么这也会使创伤反应变得更响。所以我们如何获得更多的信号和更少的噪音？这是电子学中的一个老问题。这是治疗中的一个老问题。我们正处于这样一个地方，有时通过神经学，我们比以往任何时候都更了解如何做到这一点。这可以应用于像自闭症这样的事情，以一种ABA或行为和认知疗法对于那些难以表达情感体验或说话的人来说，仍然可能对重塑隐性记忆非常有益。QEEG脑图，你可以进去并制作一张完整的大脑地图。你对每一个地方进行探测，看大脑在那些地方交流的速度有多快，
want to be where you don't feel like you can live through then that makes the trauma response louder too so how do we get more signal and less noise? It's an old problem in electronics. It's an old problem in therapy. And we are in this place where sometimes through neurology we understand more than we ever have about how to do that. could be applied to something like autism in a way that, you know, ABA or behavioral and cognitive therapy for somebody who has a hard time maybe articulating their emotional experience or speaking could still be incredibly beneficial to rewiring implicit memory. QEEG brain mapping, that you can go in and make an entire map of the brain. You ping every single place how fast the brain can talk to itself in those places,
想要处于那种你觉得无法熬过去的地方，那么创伤反应也会变得更强烈，所以我们如何才能获得更多信号而减少噪音呢？这是电子学中的一个老问题，也是治疗中的一个老问题。我们现在所处的阶段是，有时通过神经学，我们比以往任何时候都更了解如何做到这一点。这可以应用于像自闭症这样的领域，你知道，应用行为分析（ABA）或行为认知疗法对于那些在表达情感体验或说话方面有困难的人来说，仍然对重塑内隐记忆非常有益。QEEG脑电图，你可以进入并绘制整个大脑的地图。你对每一个地方进行探测，看看大脑在这些地方自我交流的速度有多快，
which gives you a whole history of cognition, because the more that you use a connection between two parts, the faster that connection gets. So if the signal is trying to go really slowly, you know, from one of the connections, then we know that that is not a place that is used much, that this is a deficit in connection, that we can go in and stem it, we can run neuromodulation through it, and force the brain to use that pathway until it gets better at it. And then behavior will get better. Dysregulation will get better. Sensory overwhelm from autism will get better. I mean, a whole lot of children have gone through just ours, you know, peak neuroscience downstairs, like their lab. And they, you know, one kid flooded when he was around cold he had sensory
这给了你整个认知的历史，因为你使用两个部分之间的连接越多，那个连接就越快。所以如果信号试图非常缓慢地从其中一个连接通过，那么我们就知道那不是一个经常使用的地方，这是一个连接缺陷，我们可以进去刺激它，我们可以通过它进行神经调节，并强迫大脑使用该路径，直到它变得更好。然后行为会好转。失调会好转。自闭症带来的感官过载会好转。我的意思是，很多孩子已经经历了我们的，你知道，楼下的Peak Neuroscience，就像他们的实验室。他们，你知道，一个孩子在寒冷时会泛滥，他有感官
overwhelm and his body could not remember you know what cold felt like intellectually his intellectual memory remembered it so he's kind of afraid of ice afraid of winter because you know if he went into um the the cold uh he remembered that his body felt something completely new that it didn't understand, and he melted down and his parents couldn't go anywhere. And Jay and Gianna, when they're doing the brain map, you know, one of the case studies that they had, I don't know if it was one that they had done a long time ago, or one of the ones that Jay was just using to teach the brain mappers, but they saw that the thalamus was sending sensory information that long-term memory wasn't getting. There was a signal gap. And so they took that signal and they stemmed it into the thalamus, what the thalamus was saying, essentially. They bridged it so that it could talk to long-term memory and send that
过载，他的身体无法记住寒冷的感觉，理智上他的智力记忆记得它，所以他有点害怕冰，害怕冬天，因为如果他进入寒冷中，他记得他的身体感觉到了某种全新的、它不理解的东西，他崩溃了，他的父母哪里也去不了。Jay和Gianna在做脑图时，他们拥有的案例研究之一——我不知道这是他们很久以前做的，还是Jay用来教脑图绘制者的案例之一——但他们看到丘脑发送的感官信息，长期记忆没有接收到。有一个信号缺口。所以他们获取了那个信号，并将其刺激到丘脑中，即丘脑本质上在说什么。他们架起了一座桥，以便它能与长期记忆对话并发送该
information around the signal gap. And then the kid was able to go outside and hold ice and, you know, be cold with limited distress. If you're using behaviorism, you're just trying to make someone like that not suffer. And I'm not just trying to talk about autism. I'm trying to talk about this as an extreme case where someone may have, be, has trouble communicating at all. Everyone deserves a conception of self that is sane and fair and human in therapy. And so that was, that's one way where in a behavioral therapy, you're going to make this person not scream even though they are suffering. You know, with this neuromodulation, which luckily worked in this case,
信息绕过信号缺口。然后那个孩子就能去外面拿冰，并且在有限的痛苦中感受寒冷。如果你使用行为主义，你只是试图让那样的人不痛苦。我不仅仅是在谈论自闭症。我是在谈论这是一个极端案例，某人可能根本难以沟通。每个人都值得在治疗中拥有一个理智、公平和人性化的自我概念。所以这就是行为疗法中，你试图让这个人不尖叫，即使他们正在受苦。你知道，通过这种神经调节，幸运的是在这个案例中起作用了，
this person is able to not suffer. And screaming without or suffering without screaming is such a sad goal for therapy to have. And it's why a lot of these directions that the industry pushes us in, I think, are bad. Another option is the stellate ganglion block. You know, why don't we look at some of these pathways as a way to rewire implicit memory? The stellate ganglion block, we have an episode interviewing one of the surgeons from Annapolis that does this procedure, but you can get it in here in Birmingham. A lot of our patients have. They go in between the C6 and the C7 vertebrae. It takes about five minutes and they
这个人能够不痛苦。而尖叫而不痛苦，或者痛苦而不尖叫，是治疗的一个如此悲哀的目标。这就是为什么行业推动我们的许多方向，我认为是糟糕的。另一个选择是星状神经节阻滞。为什么我们不把这些路径看作是重塑隐性记忆的一种方式呢？星状神经节阻滞，我们有一集采访了安纳波利斯做这个手术的外科医生之一，但你可以在伯明翰这里做。我们的许多病人已经做过了。他们在C6和C7椎骨之间进入。大约需要五分钟，他们
inject into one of the nerves that holds a, you know, chronic, a feed back and potentially a feed forward loop. And the way that we feel chronic pain, the way we feel anxiety, and they inject it with anesthesia, it forgets all of them. And it has to relearn it. And the effect on the patients who have done both, they've told me it's very much like brain spotting, but it happens all at once. You know, that's another option. Also, micronutrition, you know, you have neurons in your gut, and we don't sell the product yet. We have an interview with them. Our goal is to sell them through our website in a couple years, but you can buy them right now. Is to use, actually, we don't get a, we may by the time you hear this, if you listen to it in a year or something,
注射到其中一个神经中，该神经保持着一种慢性的、反馈和潜在的前馈回路。我们感受慢性疼痛、焦虑的方式，他们注射麻醉剂，它就忘记了所有这些。它必须重新学习。对那些两者都做过的病人的影响，他们告诉我这非常像脑点疗法，但它是一次性发生的。这是另一个选择。还有微量营养，你的肠道里有神经元，我们还没有销售该产品。我们对他们有一个采访。我们的目标是在几年内通过我们的网站销售它们，但你现在就可以买到。是使用，实际上，我们没有得到，到你听到这个的时候我们可能会得到，如果你一年后听它，
but we don't get like a kickback or anything right now. I'd like to eventually, but the code that they gave us to order just our clinic to order is taproot. Um, I think it's all caps. If you, you go to Hardy and use taproot on the thing I'm talking about, I think you get, you know, 15% off or something, but, um, micronutrition, there's an enormous amount of research where these new things are coming and very few of them have been commercialized yet. I'm positioning us to know a lot about it and be able to engage with those things as they hit the market. But right now, a lot of that research has not been commercialized. But what has been is pretty amazing.
但我们现在没有得到任何回扣之类的东西。我最终想得到，但他们给我们的代码，只是我们诊所订购的代码是taproot。我想是全大写。如果你去Hardy并使用taproot，我想你会得到15%的折扣之类的，但微量营养，有大量的研究，这些新东西正在到来，很少有被商业化的。我正在定位我们，以便了解很多关于它的信息，并能够在它们进入市场时参与这些事情。但目前，很多研究还没有被商业化。但已经商业化的那些相当令人惊叹。
Hardy Pharmaceuticals, their research studies helping children with autism, helping children with ADHD are pretty amazing. You know, Hardy Pharmaceuticals, their research studies, helping children with autism, helping children with ADHD are pretty amazing. I went off my antidepressant when I was talking to Corey and Jared on the podcast episode, and they said a lot of people go off their antidepressant when they take Hardy. I was like, whoa, whoa, whoa, don't tell people to go off their meds. And then they sent me some of the product and I was taking it. And I realized I just forgot to take my antidepressant because I didn't feel bad and I wasn't withdrawing from it at lunchtime. So I didn't remember. And, um, you know, I, and I'm, you know, an old guy, like, uh, with children, these micronutrients have been able to change ADHD, ASD type behavior,
Hardy Pharmaceuticals，他们的研究帮助自闭症儿童，帮助多动症儿童，相当令人惊叹。我在播客节目中与Corey和Jared交谈时，我停用了我的抗抑郁药，他们说很多人在服用Hardy时会停用他们的抗抑郁药。我说：“哇，哇，哇，不要告诉人们停用他们的药物。”然后他们寄给我一些产品，我正在服用它。我意识到我只是忘记服用我的抗抑郁药了，因为我感觉并不糟糕，而且我在午餐时间没有戒断反应。所以我没记住。而且，我是一个有孩子的老家伙，这些微量营养素已经能够改变多动症、自闭症类型的行为，
because a lot of times, even if you're taking, you know, something that is going to, you know, ramp up a high beta to make you focus or something that is going to, um, you know, reuptake a neurotransmitter, if you don't have the precursors to make the neurotransmitter, it's just not there. If you have gut inflammation all the time, you can be on a whole hell of a lot of, um, antidepressants or stimulants or whatever. And like, unless you're eating the benzo that minute, it's just not going to move the needle on your mood that much. Like that's, you know, get off the treadmill if you want to slow down, you know, stop trying to hold on to the emergency brake. So these are things that are part of therapy. I would, I don't have any direct experience with
因为很多时候，即使你正在服用某种会提高高β波让你专注的东西，或者某种会重新摄取神经递质的东西，如果你没有制造神经递质的前体，它就是不存在。如果你一直有肠道炎症，你可以服用一大堆抗抑郁药或兴奋剂或任何东西。除非你那一分钟在吃苯二氮卓类药物，否则它对你的情绪不会有太大影响。就像，如果你想慢下来就离开跑步机，停止试图抓住紧急制动器。所以这些是治疗的一部分。我没有任何直接经验
this in children. But a lot of people with ASD who go to an intuitive myofascial release therapist, you know, we have an ROI. We work with a lot of people who do myofascial release, but they also do, you know, more intuitive body work as physical therapists, and we'll have an ROI to talk to them. They'll have an ROI to talk to us from the patient, a release of information, and we collaborate on trying to work with a repressed memory that maybe the body remembers, but the person doesn't remember because they were drugged. They were unconscious. Children don't make memories the same. So when I'm saying that there are other ways to get at the soul, to get into the human, these are evidence-based, not woo-woo.
在儿童身上。但许多患有自闭症谱系障碍的人，他们去看直觉肌筋膜释放治疗师，我们有ROI（信息发布授权）。我们与许多做肌筋膜释放的人合作，但他们也做更直觉的身体工作作为物理治疗师，我们会有一个ROI与他们交谈。他们会有一个来自病人的ROI与我们交谈，我们合作尝试处理一个压抑的记忆，也许身体记得，但人因为被下药而不记得。他们当时失去了知觉。孩子们的记忆方式不同。所以当我说是还有其他方法可以触及灵魂，进入人性时，这些是基于证据的，而不是玄学的。
I'm not talking about shamanism and ketamine and psilocybin and a lot of the other stuff that we talk about. These are hardcore evidence-based ways to do that that are easy and available in here that you probably have never heard of because our culture doesn't value that kind of thinking. It's easier for us to just turn the symptom off by giving the child a huge dose of an ADHD drug and teaching them to shut up and be quiet.
我不是在谈论萨满教、氯胺酮和裸盖菇素以及我们谈论的许多其他东西。这些是硬核的、基于证据的方法，简单且在这里可用，你可能从未听说过，因为我们的文化不重视那种思维。对我们来说，通过给孩子大剂量的多动症药物并教他们闭嘴安静，来关闭症状更容易。
And so those are examples of what I mean when I say that therapy has to change. Things like brain spotting are amazing. When I opened, I was the second person in the state to do brain spotting that I could find. I've never found anyone before that. Everyone thought it was kind of weird. Now you're almost kind of behind the times if you don't have that. It's growing a whole lot faster than EMDR is.
所以这就是我所说的“治疗必须改变”的意思。像脑点疗法这样的东西是惊人的。当我开业时，我是该州第二个做脑点疗法的人。我之前从未发现任何人。每个人都认为它有点奇怪。现在如果你没有那个，你几乎有点落后于时代了。它的增长速度比EMDR快得多。
And it's growing a whole lot faster than EMDR is because it works a lot better. It goes deeper. It goes a lot faster in less time. Something like emotional transformation therapy. Now that's the new weird thing that just taproot therapy does that no one else does. And people think it's weird, but the, some of the people who either said something to me, you know, nicely, uh, to my face about brain spotting being pseudoscience or something kind of bad about me behind my back. I know who you are. I've looked you up. You have the brain spotting
它的增长速度比EMDR快得多，因为它效果好得多。它更深入。它在更短的时间内走得更快。像情绪转化疗法（ETT）。那是Taproot Therapy独有的新奇东西，没有其他人做。人们认为它很奇怪，但有些人要么当面礼貌地对我说脑点疗法是伪科学，要么在我背后说我坏话。我知道你是谁。我查过你。你有脑点疗法
training. Now it's on your little psychology today. This stuff is coming. You know, I know I was weird when I did brain spotting. Now I'm doing ETT. It's, you know, mixed with brain spotting. We also have a couple of different integrative procedures at Taproot. If you know me in person and have talked to me, you know what they are. We've probably talked about them. If not, you know, I don't know. Just wait. There'll be stuff that comes out. But there's a whole lot of other things when you start integrating this stuff.
培训。现在它在你的小“今日心理学”页面上了。这些东西正在到来。我知道我做脑点疗法时很奇怪。现在我正在做ETT。它与脑点疗法混合在一起。我们在Taproot还有几个不同的整合程序。如果你私下认识我并和我谈过，你就知道它们是什么。我们可能谈论过它们。如果没有，我不知道。等着吧。会有东西出来的。但当你开始整合这些东西时，还有很多其他事情。
And I had said in the second part of this episode or this series that the demand for specialization, that a consumption-oriented, profit-seeking medical system is going to be interested in, they detract from the ability to do integrative work, which psychology is inherently an integrative discipline. You can't take anthropology out of it. You can't take, I don't even think you can take spirituality out of it, you know, and that can be a secular spirituality. You can't take anthropology and mythology and the body out of it, you know, and that can be a secular spirituality. You can't take anthropology and mythology and the body out of it in a way that we've tried to. And that is a dead end. It is wrong. If you continue to drive the car against that wall, you're just going to hurt people.
我在这一集或系列的第二部分说过，对专业化的需求，一个以消费为导向、追求利润的医疗系统会感兴趣，它们削弱了进行整合工作的能力，而心理学本质上是一门整合学科。你不能把人类学从中剔除。我甚至认为你不能把灵性从中剔除，那可以是世俗的灵性。你不能把人类学、神话学和身体从中剔除，我们尝试过这样做。那是一条死胡同。它是错误的。如果你继续开车撞向那堵墙，你只会伤害人。
You're not going to go anywhere. And I hope we don't do that for much longer. So when we come back to implicit memory and how to change that i think the biggest thing is that the least amount of shame that you can have the better because shame will never help you change but everyone's inner critic feels like because most people who have allowed inner critic had some kind of neglect or abuse you know they either were abused and told these things directly, or they were neglected and they told themselves this stuff in their own head. You know, if we feel shamed, if we make ourselves feel bad, if we punish ourselves, that will change our behavior.
你不会去任何地方。我希望我们不要再那样做了。所以当我们回到隐性记忆以及如何改变它时，我认为最重要的事情是，你拥有的羞耻感越少越好，因为羞耻感永远不会帮助你改变，但每个人的内在批评者都觉得，因为大多数允许内在批评者存在的人都有某种忽视或虐待，他们要么被虐待并被直接告知这些事情，要么被忽视，他们在自己的脑海中告诉自己这些东西。如果我们感到羞耻，如果我们让自己感觉糟糕，如果我们惩罚自己，那会改变我们的行为。
That is the enemy of change. Shame is the opposite. And something like cognitive behavioral therapy is a lot more likely to leave you feeling ashamed than another kind, especially just pure behaviorism. So, you know, when you come back and you think about like those stages of grief, those ideas that we deny, and then we get angry and we whatever, they're really like stages of change, because what they are, are there ways that we just accept something? You know, myself going back to therapy, being this relationship between self and the world, um, myself says, I don't want to accept this. I will make it not real by being so angry that my emotion will be magic and it will bring him back to life. You know, he's still dead.
那是改变的敌人。羞耻感是相反的。像认知行为疗法比其他种类更容易让你感到羞耻，特别是纯行为主义。所以，当你回来思考那些悲伤阶段，那些我们否认，然后我们生气，然后我们无论如何的想法时，它们真的就像改变的阶段，因为它们是什么，它们是我们只是接受某事的方式。我的自我回到治疗中，作为自我与世界之间的这种关系，我的自我说：“我不想接受这个。我会通过如此愤怒来使它不真实，我的情绪将是魔法，它会让他复活。”他仍然死了。
Well, I'm just going to go on about my life. I'm going to deny it. I'm going to pretend that it didn't happen. And my denial will manifest some external reality. Doesn't matter. He's still dead. These things are how the ego resists change. And we have to come to some better understanding of what implicit memory is
好吧，我只是要继续我的生活。我要否认它。我要假装它没有发生。我的否认会表现出某种外部现实。没关系。他仍然死了。这些事情是自我如何抵制改变的。我们必须对隐性记忆是什么有更好的理解
if we're going to have better models of therapy. You if you look at aa groups aa is very interesting to me because it's it's it is it's not a religion in a bad way but it does function like a religion you know socially anthropologically and that you have a lot of people that are saying the same words but they don't always mean the same thing you know um are, and if you look at the AA groups that really work, the people that are trying to make themselves feel bad and make you feel bad, um, because they think that that's productive. Those are the ones that are kind of toxic. Like they don't go somewhere. They don't lead people somewhere. Good. If you look at the ones that really go and inspire and all those people go out and they start their own. And, you know, those are the ones where they're maybe using the same language, but it's about how you
如果我们想有更好的治疗模型。如果你看看AA小组，AA对我来说非常有趣，因为它不是一种糟糕意义上的宗教，但它确实像宗教一样运作，在社会学、人类学上，你有很多人在说同样的话，但他们并不总是意味着同样的事情。如果你看看真正有效的AA小组，那些试图让自己感觉糟糕并让你感觉糟糕的人，因为他们认为那是富有成效的。那些是有点毒性的。他们没有去任何地方。他们没有引导人们去任何好的地方。如果你看看那些真正去激励，所有那些人出去并开始他们自己的小组的人，那些是他们可能使用相同语言，但它是关于你如何
have to accept this stuff. It's not that you need to feel bad, you know? What is the Jung quote about, you know, the trauma or the, you know, biological imperatives that you have that you're not managing? They're not your fault, but they're still your responsibility. You know, you have to be accountable for your, your lack of progress in changing them, but you don't need to feel ashamed that you are imperfect and have failed. And that is a hard circle to square. And so that's why I think the brain-based medicine, because I love existential therapy. If I'd never discovered brain spotting, I'd be talking about Yalom and Jung and all this stuff forever. The reason that I, you know, take digressions to talk about brain spotting and ETT and this other stuff is because they do the same thing that reams and reams of really good therapy do. You know, I used to do
必须接受这些东西。并不是说你需要感到难过，你知道吗？荣格关于创伤或者你无法掌控的生物本能的那句名言是怎么说的？它们不是你的错，但你仍然要为此负责。你知道，你必须为你未能改变它们而承担责任，但你不需要因为自己不完美且失败了而感到羞耻。这是一个很难两全的局面。这就是为什么我认为基于大脑的疗法很重要，因为我热爱存在主义疗法。如果我从未发现脑点疗法（Brainspotting），我可能会永远谈论亚隆、荣格和所有这些东西。我之所以会岔开话题去谈论脑点疗法、ETT和其他东西，是因为它们能达到与大量高质量疗法相同的效果。你知道，我过去常做
the hypnotic experiencing and the person would be in the trance state and you're like, what's on the other side of the wall? And they're like, nothing, nothing. And then you see something click and then they're like, I'm a little girl and there's another little girl on the other side of the wall and she's crying and I can hear it. And you know, sometimes I understand the metaphor and sometimes I don't, but the point is that the patient understands it. Brain spotting makes that same change where your body has a somatic release and re-experiencing it completes this emotional arc and then all of a sudden your dreams are weird and you have this period of renewed creativity of renewed empathy of renewed insight you you have motivation and then you come
催眠体验，当人处于恍惚状态时，你会问，墙的另一边有什么？他们会说，什么都没有，什么都没有。然后你看到某种东西被触发了，他们会说，我是一个小女孩，墙的另一边有另一个小女孩，她在哭，我能听到。你知道，有时我能理解其中的隐喻，有时不能，但重点是患者理解了。脑点疗法能带来同样的改变，你的身体会产生躯体释放，重新体验它，从而完成这个情感弧线，然后突然之间，你的梦变得很奇怪，你经历了一段重新获得创造力、重新获得同理心、重新获得洞察力的时期，你有了动力，然后你
back and you feel great but then you also the anxiety comes back because you're wondering if the change is permanent and we're on to the next cycle. You know, that happens in normal therapy, but these, these tricks, they speed it up, you know, vagus nerve stimulators, most of what's out there I wouldn't buy right now, but that technology is going somewhere. And you look at the way that you could retrain somebody with autism instead of just positively or negatively reinforcing them, that you could actually regulate them, you know, teach them to regulate themselves with this electronic aid so we have all of these new ways of getting into implicit memory which to me is kind of what all the therapy modalities that are worth anything have been describing but they disagree over the semantics of the language of how they conceptualize the unconscious because well, one, it's a place that in the brain that is beneath language and time.
回来，感觉很棒，但随后焦虑又回来了，因为你不知道这种改变是否是永久的，我们又进入了下一个循环。你知道，这在常规疗法中也会发生，但这些技巧加快了速度，你知道，迷走神经刺激器，目前市面上大多数产品我不会买，但这项技术正在进步。看看你如何能重新训练自闭症患者，而不是仅仅进行正向或负向强化，你可以真正地调节他们，你知道，用这种电子辅助设备教他们自我调节，所以我们有所有这些进入内隐记忆的新方法，对我来说，这正是所有有价值的治疗模式一直在描述的东西，但它们在如何概念化潜意识的语义语言上存在分歧，因为，第一，它在大脑中是一个位于语言和时间之下的地方。
So it doesn't really, you can't say, Hey, when I went there, there was a room with red wallpaper. It more is like a set of symbols or experiential techniques or you know, ego dissolving mindfulness practices. There's some way of entering implicit memory to encode it and decode it. I mean, a lot of newer research is coming, um, out around something called memory reconsolidation theory. You know, that a lot of the things that we would call trauma are actually, you know, fragments and implicit memory deciding to handle the same situation or stimuli like two or three different
所以它真的，你不能说，嘿，当我到那里时，有一个贴着红色壁纸的房间。它更像是一组符号或体验式技术，或者你知道，自我消解的正念练习。有一种进入内隐记忆来编码和解码它的方法。我的意思是，很多新的研究正在围绕一种叫做记忆重巩固理论的东西展开。你知道，我们称之为创伤的很多东西实际上是，你知道，碎片和内隐记忆，决定同时以两三种不同的
ways at once and when it's trying to do that it's uh you know pulling itself and pulling you you know in these two or three different directions and that the the memory is not just like hanging out in the brain all the time on a record or a hard drive It's more like a zip file or a filing cabinet. And that like, you have to go get the memory out and unzip it or take the file out of the cabinet and then spread all this stuff on the table. And then you can play with it for a little bit. And the problem with that going back to signal to noise ratio is like, it sucks because you have to sit in a traumatized memory in some way. And so the techniques are designed for the patient to be in less distress, you know, all therapy techniques, you know, when they're working are designed for
方式处理相同的情况或刺激，当它试图这样做时，它是在，你知道，拉扯它自己，也在把你，你知道，拉向这两三个不同的方向，而且记忆并不只是像一直挂在大脑里的唱片或硬盘上。它更像是一个压缩文件或一个文件柜。就像，你必须把记忆取出来并解压，或者把文件从柜子里拿出来，然后把所有这些东西摊在桌子上。然后你可以玩弄它一会儿。回到信噪比的问题，这很糟糕，因为你必须以某种方式坐在创伤记忆中。所以这些技术的目的是让患者处于较少的痛苦中，你知道，所有的治疗技术，你知道，当它们起作用时，都是为了
the patient to be in less distress than they are when they're just acutely re-experiencing the trauma so that they can go back into it, but rewire it a little bit. So we've modified that memory somewhat. And then when we put it back and recompress it into the zip file or put the file back in the cabinet, we've cleaned it up some, you know, and we've made those things agree. So, I mean, the first reason that the unconscious, the language about the unconscious, implicit memory, the tertiary memory, whatever you want to call it, the brainstem is that, um, that we disagree on it is that it doesn't really fit into cognition. It's this thing that's underneath language, you know, if you, um, but, therapists have different things that they're good at. And a theory that I have had for a really long time, one of the reasons why I'm so integrative is that different therapists and different kinds of therapy are actually messing with different types of memory.
让患者处于比他们仅仅在剧烈地重新体验创伤时更少的痛苦中，这样他们就可以回到创伤中，但对其进行一点点重连。所以我们已经在某种程度上修改了那个记忆。然后当我们把它放回去并重新压缩成压缩文件，或者把文件放回柜子里时，我们已经清理了一些，你知道，我们已经让那些东西达成了一致。所以，我的意思是，关于潜意识、内隐记忆、三级记忆，或者你想怎么称呼它，脑干，我们对它有分歧的第一个原因是，它并不真正符合认知。它是那种在语言之下的东西，你知道，如果你，嗯，但是，治疗师有他们擅长的不同东西。我有一个很长时间以来的理论，我之所以如此整合的原因之一是，不同的治疗师和不同种类的疗法实际上是在处理不同类型的记忆。
There's not one kind of memory. It's not just like, okay, here's a bunch of blue files or here's a bunch of CDRs that I burned and I'm going to keep them in the back of my brain. I'm dating myself. If you don't know what a CDR is, um, you're younger than me. Um, so like, it isn't that what it is, is like these overlapping networks of like relational memory, you know, and we can start to see these things like relational memory is, you know, how I want to be perceived, how I'm perceived these assumptions that I make about communication, identity, senses of self, you know, somebody with an attachment disorder is going to have very impaired, you know, functional memory. There's also like visual spatial memory, which if you're having a flashback, you know, to when your buddy
记忆不止一种。它不仅仅是，好吧，这里有一堆蓝色文件，或者这里有一堆我刻录的CDR，我要把它们保存在大脑后部。我暴露了我的年龄。如果你不知道什么是CDR，嗯，你比我年轻。嗯，所以它不是那样的，它是什么呢，就像这些重叠的关系记忆网络，你知道，我们可以开始看到这些东西，比如关系记忆是，你知道，我希望被如何看待，我如何被看待，我关于沟通、身份、自我感的这些假设，你知道，有依恋障碍的人会有非常受损的，你知道，功能性记忆。还有视觉空间记忆，如果你有闪回，你知道，回到你的伙伴
got, you know, killed in Vietnam or something, like, and you're seeing it, you know, that is this visual spatial memory, which is really one of the more rare types of PTSD. And we associate it, I think, more with PTSD because of movies, basically, it's a visual medium, and we see that people have flashbacks. There's also like kinesthetic memory, how my body is supposed to be budgeting energy at any time. And I mean, like, I don't want this to turn into a science lesson. And some of this is highly speculative based on science, but like, so for example, like most of the newer research on how brains work regarding trauma and memory is not around like structure. And we're going to move away from that conception. Like, it's not just going to be like, okay, this is the part of the
在越南被杀的时候或者类似的事情，就像，你看到了它，你知道，这就是视觉空间记忆，这确实是PTSD中比较罕见的类型之一。我认为我们更多地将它与PTSD联系在一起是因为电影，基本上，它是一种视觉媒介，我们看到人们有闪回。还有动觉记忆，我的身体在任何时候应该如何分配能量。我的意思是，我不想让这变成一堂科学课。其中一些是基于科学的高度推测，但比如，例如，大多数关于大脑如何处理创伤和记忆的较新研究并不是围绕结构。我们将远离那个概念。就像，它不会只是像，好吧，这就是大脑中
brain that memorizes trauma. You know, those things that you had to learn about, like, well, here's the thalamus and that's the alarm bell of the brain and the amygdala releases the cortisol. Like, you know, that works to a point, but it's like not really working to teach us any more information. Like a lot of the better research now is around something called ERPs or event related potentials. And that's a replicable thing where you can figure out how networks in the brain talk by getting someone to wear a QEG, like a quantified EEG cap and looking at how brain function changes when you do a task that is replicatable, right? So like if I, there's, there's hundreds of these, but like if I say, okay, Hey, I want you to look at this apple while you're in a QEG cap. And I'm like, I want you to memorize what this apple looks like. It's red.
记忆创伤的部分。你知道，那些你必须学习的东西，比如，嗯，这是丘脑，那是大脑的警报器，杏仁核释放皮质醇。就像，你知道，那在一定程度上有效，但它并没有真正起到教给我们更多信息的作用。现在很多更好的研究是围绕一种叫做ERP或事件相关电位的东西。这是一个可复制的东西，你可以通过让某人戴上QEG，即定量脑电图帽，并观察当你执行一个可复制的任务时大脑功能如何变化，来弄清楚大脑中的网络是如何交流的，对吧？所以如果我，有，有数百个这样的，但如果我说，好吧，嘿，我想让你在戴着QEG帽时看着这个苹果。我想让你记住这个苹果看起来是什么样子的。它是红色的。
And think about it. And you look at the apple and you think about it. And then I take it away. And I say, okay, just keep thinking about that apple. What I'm doing is I'm making you keep that in your visual working memory. And when you are concentrating on something, whether it's there or it's not, that is in your visual working memory, there is a network that activates in the brain. So this is one event related potential, right? And it's called the sustained posterior contralateral negativity. That's just, you know, one of hundreds that we
然后思考它。你看着苹果并思考它。然后我把它拿走。我说，好吧，继续思考那个苹果。我正在做的是让你把它保持在你的视觉工作记忆中。当你专注于某件事时，无论它是否存在，那都在你的视觉工作记忆中，大脑中有一个网络会被激活。所以这是一个事件相关电位，对吧？它被称为持续后侧对侧负波。这只是，你知道，数百个我们
know. So when you watch something like Elon Musk do, youink and Elon Musk says, you know, we just got this guy to move the mouse around on the keyboard or move the mouse around on the screen, even though he's paralyzed and doesn't have access to his hands or can't move them or something like that. What they're doing is they're getting him, they're putting the cap on him and they're saying, hey, think go right, think go right, think go right. Okay, now think go left, think go left, think go left. Okay, every time we told you to think about the mouse going right, let's look at the consistent signal in all of this data. And now we're going to program this cap that every single time it sees that signal, it'll discard the other ones. But when it sees this consistent signal that we have, you know, associated with you thinking go left, we're going to make the mouse go left. Like that's how Neuralink works. That's how those things work. You know, if we wanted to do that by hand, we could do that at Taproot. Like we could put the QEG cap on you and do that. I'm not going to do that. Don't, don't ask me, but it's, it's not
知道的其中之一。所以当你看到像埃隆·马斯克做的那样，你看到埃隆·马斯克说，你知道，我们刚刚让这个人移动键盘上的鼠标，或者在屏幕上移动鼠标，即使他瘫痪了，没有手的使用权，或者不能移动它们之类的。他们正在做的是，他们给他戴上帽子，然后说，嘿，想向右，想向右，想向右。好吧，现在想向左，想向左，想向左。好吧，每次我们让你想鼠标向右移动时，让我们看看所有这些数据中的一致信号。现在我们要对这个帽子进行编程，每当它看到那个信号时，它就会丢弃其他的。但当它看到我们已经，你知道，与你思考向左移动相关联的一致信号时，我们会让鼠标向左移动。这就是Neuralink的工作方式。这就是那些东西的工作方式。你知道，如果我们想手工做这件事，我们可以在Taproot做。我们可以给你戴上QEG帽并做到这一点。我不会那样做。别，别问我，但这并不
terribly hard. Like this stuff is available and i think um that a lot of the qeg research that i've seen what it's doing is validating this assumption that i've always had that different kinds of therapy are treating trauma and different kinds of memory which brings me to like a bigger problem with implicit memory and that is the idea of trauma like one of the idea reasons that the idea of trauma is so confusing is because like we don't know what it is. There's like the Instagram definition of like trauma is anything that happens to me when I'm emotionally immature. And everyone that I've ever dated is a toxic, compulsive narcissist.
特别难。就像这些东西是可用的，我认为，嗯，我看到的很多QEG研究，它所做的是验证了我一直有的一个假设，即不同种类的疗法正在治疗创伤和不同种类的记忆，这让我想到了内隐记忆的一个更大的问题，那就是创伤的概念，就像创伤这个概念之所以如此令人困惑的原因之一是因为，就像我们不知道它是什么。有像Instagram上定义的，创伤就是我在情感不成熟时发生的任何事情。我约会过的每个人都是有毒的、强迫性的自恋者。
And everything that I have is a trauma response. And like whatever, it's this language has entered the mainstream culture. It's very overapplied. And then there are other people that say, well, PTSD, you know, is this set of these circumstances. Now there's other people who don't meet those circumstances, those exact criteria for PTSD. Like for example, in the definition of PTSD, they say re-experiencing. Okay.
我拥有的一切都是创伤反应。随便吧，这种语言已经进入了主流文化。它被过度应用了。然后还有其他人说，嗯，PTSD，你知道，是这一系列情况。现在还有其他人不符合那些情况，那些PTSD的确切标准。比如，在PTSD的定义中，他们说重新体验。好吧。
What does that mean? Like, does that mean that I have a visual flashback? Does that mean that my, what if my mood is always like at a hundred million degrees, you know, Celsius, because I, my body is physically re-experiencing it, but I don't know that, you know, re-experiencing what kind of memory, where, how, right. And that's why there's these kind of like, um, I don't know, like kitchen table degree, you know, terms that crop up is because the DSM has moved so far away from what a lot of therapists like need, how they need to conceptualize things with their model that you'll see things like complex PTSD, that it isn't, you know, an acute
那是什么意思？就像，那意味着我有视觉闪回吗？那意味着我的，如果我的情绪总是处于一亿摄氏度，你知道，因为我，我的身体在物理上重新体验它，但我不知道，你知道，重新体验什么样的记忆，在哪里，怎么做，对吧？这就是为什么会出现这些，嗯，我不知道，就像厨房餐桌学位，你知道，术语，因为DSM已经离很多治疗师需要的，他们如何需要用他们的模型来概念化事物太远了，你会看到像复杂性PTSD这样的东西，它不是，你知道，一种急性的
re-experiencing, but these things are invading like all aspects of your life. And you didn't have enough of a break from the trauma. Again, there's not a definition for CPTSD because it's not a diagnosis in the DSM. It's people trying to develop a language that is more useful than the language that is in the DSM. So like, you know, there's also kinesthetic memory, you know, the way that your body holds the trauma. There are, there is an increasing amount of evidence that when you are thinking to yourself, like when you were problem solving, when you were praying, when you were obsessing, when you were having like a very cognitive self-referential process, that there's some ERPs that go along with that. It would explain a lot of things that I see clinically. And so again, like I'm not just
重新体验，但这些东西正在侵入你生活的方方面面。而且你没有从创伤中得到足够的休息。同样，没有CPTSD的定义，因为它不是DSM中的诊断。这是人们试图开发一种比DSM中的语言更有用的语言。所以，你知道，还有动觉记忆，你知道，你的身体保持创伤的方式。有越来越多的证据表明，当你自己在思考时，比如当你解决问题时，当你祈祷时，当你沉迷时，当你进行像非常认知的自我参照过程时，有一些ERP会伴随发生。这可以解释我在临床上看到的很多事情。所以同样，我不是在这里
spitballing here. Like I do read a whole lot of research for somebody that dislikes the current state of academia. I do use it for what it's useful for. And I'm not like out in the woods making stuff up entirely. But again, like you kind of have to read through it. And when I read through it based on my clinical experience, this is what I see. Trauma needs to be thought about like it is different types of impairment and different types of memory. There may be somebody who's flashing back to an event and you make that go away with EMDR. EMDR works pretty well for, you know, flashback re-experiencing. But then, um, relationally they were abused by a parent. They were in a controlling relationship. They never learned that they could have agency. So they go through this pattern that is, you know, maybe looks like a personality disorder or a
胡说八道。对于一个不喜欢当前学术界状态的人来说，我确实读了很多研究。我确实把它用在有用的地方。我并不是在树林里完全编造东西。但同样，你必须读透它。当我根据我的临床经验读透它时，这就是我所看到的。创伤需要被认为就像它是不同类型的损伤和不同类型的记忆。可能有人正在闪回到一个事件，你用EMDR让它消失。EMDR对于，你知道，闪回重新体验效果相当好。但随后，嗯，在关系上他们被父母虐待了。他们处于一段控制关系中。他们从未学会他们可以拥有自主权。所以他们经历了这种模式，你知道，看起来可能像人格障碍或
reactive attachment style. That is every time I'm in a relationship, I'm trying to figure out what to do with you and how to get power over you. And I think it's a game and you're just hanging out, but I keep trying to like, Oh no, no, I don't want any authority. And then resenting you because you didn't do the thing that I wanted to do right. Cause I gave up all my authority to you and I'm just totally toxic and a mess. Well, that is trauma too, right? It just isn't this visual flashback re-experiencing. It is a relational memory, you know, how I want to be perceived, how you perceive me. So that's always kind of how I've worked is like, what's going on and what spheres is this person traumatized in? And then how do I move towards them? And when I talk to people about it, they seem to like that. And I think it's a conception that at least I haven't heard, um, of before, but I can't really unsee it. And you, you have to,
反应性依恋风格。那就是每次我在一段关系中，我都在试图弄清楚该怎么对付你，以及如何获得对你的权力。我以为这是一个游戏，而你只是在闲逛，但我一直试图，哦不，不，我不想要任何权威。然后因为你没有做我想做的事情而怨恨你。因为我把所有的权威都交给了你，我完全是有毒的，一团糟。好吧，那也是创伤，对吧？它只是不是这种视觉闪回重新体验。它是关系记忆，你知道，我希望被如何看待，你如何看待我。所以这就是我一直工作的方式，就像，发生了什么，这个人在哪些领域受到了创伤？然后我如何走向他们？当我与人们谈论它时，他们似乎喜欢那样。我认为这是一个至少我以前没有听说过的概念，但我真的无法忽视它。而且你，你必须，
it's so hard to think about this concept because people are like, well, you can't prove that or whatever. And like, yeah, you're right. Like I can't even put it into language, let alone a number to research it in the way that you want, but that doesn't make mean that it isn't real i mean we talked about conceptions of self um and greeks trying to tell the difference between movement thought and life you know basically um they go back a long ways you know there's a really good argument that you could make that plato is like the first depth psychologist when he's talking about the tripartite nature of the soul and how we have these conflicting drives within us that want to fight. Because he's saying, wait a minute, this feels good and also that feels good. But normally men choose, you know, an honor over pleasure, even though pleasure is good.
思考这个概念太难了，因为人们会说，嗯，你无法证明这一点之类的。是的，你是对的。就像我甚至无法用语言表达它，更不用说用数字来以你想要的方式研究它了，但这并不意味着它不是真实的。我的意思是，我们谈到了自我概念，嗯，希腊人试图区分运动、思想和生命，你知道，基本上，嗯，他们追溯得很远，你知道，你可以提出一个很好的论点，即柏拉图是第一个深度心理学家，当他在谈论灵魂的三重本质以及我们内心有这些相互冲突的驱动力想要战斗时。因为他在说，等一下，这感觉很好，那也感觉很好。但通常人们选择，你知道，荣誉胜过快乐，即使快乐是好的。
So maybe somehow honor scratches another itch for pleasure. You know, like he's trying to figure out why people um do what they do uh so um one way to think about it is that like when you have a democracy right like uh i said when not we do when you have a democracy like you have to elect representatives because if somebody was like holding you down to watch c-SPAN all day to fight to fight and like vote and care about every single issue, the amount of information like you would need would be so insane that no one could do it. And so what do you do? Like you elect representatives and then we make a body of those representatives and then those representatives, they have the
所以也许某种程度上荣誉抓住了快乐的另一个痒处。你知道，就像他在试图弄清楚为什么人们，嗯，做他们所做的事情，嗯，所以，嗯，一种思考方式是，就像当你有一个民主国家时，对吧，嗯，我说当不是我们做，当你有一个民主国家时，你必须选举代表，因为如果有人像整天按着你让你看C-SPAN去战斗，去战斗，去关心每一个问题，你需要的信息量就像会如此疯狂，以至于没有人能做到。所以你做什么？就像你选举代表，然后我们组成一个代表机构，然后那些代表，他们有
same problem. So they represent, they elect somebody to be the head of the Senate Judiciary Committee. I mean, they make, and that's kind of what your brain is doing. It can't tell you to think within your ego structure and your prefrontal cortex about every single, about breathing, you know, that's an unconscious process. Like, but breathing is something that you have to do. And you're sort of always doing it the same way and adjusting it maybe based on how much oxygen you're using or how fast your muscles are going through enzyme reactions. So that's pretty easy to set on autopilot. But when you're dealing with an animal that can learn more about in its environment than it knows, right? Like humans can. Like their brainstem is learning things from when you were six years old and you don't know what they are and they could be people aren't safe or this kind of conversation doesn't end well or like never take responsibility in this situation in this context.
同样的问题。所以他们代表，他们选举某人担任参议院司法委员会主席。我的意思是，他们制造，这正是你的大脑正在做的事情。它不能让你在你的自我结构和前额叶皮层中思考每一个，关于呼吸，你知道，那是一个潜意识过程。就像，但呼吸是你必须做的事情。而且你通常总是以同样的方式做它，并根据你消耗多少氧气或你的肌肉进行多少酶反应来调整它。所以这很容易设置为自动驾驶。但当你面对一个可以在其环境中学习比它所知道的更多的动物时，对吧？就像人类可以。就像他们的脑干正在学习你六岁时的事情，而你不知道它们是什么，它们可能是人们不安全，或者这种对话没有好结果，或者像在这种情况下在这种背景下永远不要承担责任。
Unconsciously, you think that you're just going through the day and you have a reason for what you do and you do, but you don't know what that reason is. And that's why the unconscious is inherently irrational. Like it doesn't fit within reason because it's acting on information that is like maybe genetic, you know, maybe learned. And maybe some like other weirder mixture, like epigenetically inherited from mom based on things going on in the womb that are getting you ready for the world you're coming into. There's just all of this stuff that's going on. And it would be like drinking from the fire hose to try and think about all of that. You know, a graphics card is like another comparison. If you build computers, you know, the processor is able to make decisions about any kind of information. So it's like a great general tool for number crunching. But if you're playing a video game, or you're building an app, or you're doing some kind of information. So it's like a great general tool for number crunching. But if you're playing a video game or you're building an app
潜意识里，你认为你只是在过日子，你做某事有理由，你确实有，但你不知道那个理由是什么。这就是为什么潜意识本质上是非理性的。因为它不符合理性，因为它基于的信息可能是遗传的，你知道，可能是习得的。也许还有其他更奇怪的混合，比如基于子宫里发生的事情从妈妈那里表观遗传继承的，这些事情正在让你为即将进入的世界做好准备。所有这些事情都在发生。试图思考所有这些就像从消防水带里喝水一样。你知道，显卡是另一个比较。如果你组装电脑，你知道，处理器能够对任何类型的信息做出决定。所以它就像一个用于数字运算的伟大通用工具。但如果你在玩电子游戏，或者你在构建一个应用程序，或者你在做某种信息。所以它就像一个用于数字运算的伟大通用工具。但如果你在玩电子游戏，或者你在构建一个应用程序
or you're doing some kind of like data crunching thing, it's gonna offload everything to the graphics processor, like the GPU, because the graphics card is very good at doing a very similar kind of math problem hundreds of times. The CPU is very good at doing a random, completely new and inventive kind of math problem quickly the gpu is kind of doing things that are like one number different a million times really fast and so the base of
或者你在做某种像数据处理的事情，它会把所有东西卸载到图形处理器，比如GPU，因为显卡非常擅长成百上千次地做一种非常相似的数学问题。CPU非常擅长快速地做一种随机的、全新的和创造性的数学问题，GPU有点像在做一些数字不同但一百万次非常快的事情，所以你的大脑基础
your brain is kind of like the graphics card um and i think that's like why freudian language is like so weird and why even though because we haven't embraced this new understanding the the language of freud stuck around in like politics and english and like as a lens to look at like history and things way longer than it ever should have but and but to me like that's where freud is entirely wrong but i understand why his language appeals to people is because when freud is saying hey like you have an unconscious and that unconscious is something that is at odds with what you want to do. It comes from nature. It comes from the animal within you
有点像显卡，嗯，我认为这就是为什么弗洛伊德的语言如此奇怪，以及为什么即使因为我们没有拥抱这种新的理解，弗洛伊德的语言在政治和英语中，以及作为观察历史和事物的镜头，停留的时间比它应该停留的时间长得多，但对我来说，这就是弗洛伊德完全错误的地方，但我理解为什么他的语言吸引人，因为当弗洛伊德说嘿，就像你有一个潜意识，那个潜意识是与你想做的事情相冲突的东西。它来自自然。它来自你内心的动物
that wants to just have sex and fight and like is thinking about having sex with your family or all the things that Freud said, this drive for competition and dominance. He's thinking about it like something, the unconscious, like something that is logical. It just disagrees with your logical function. He's thinking about it like something that is self-motivated, that wants something, that wants to go somewhere. That like is this other being riding around in your head and trying to defeat you by shutting down things in your body and like pulling strings to get what it wants. Like it's this hitchhiker that is trying to hijack your brain. And like that doesn't work because the unconscious isn't that it's implicit reactions that yeah they do show up as symbol and like sometimes these things do have like almost a metaphorical or
想要只是做爱和战斗，并且正在考虑与你的家人做爱，或者弗洛伊德所说的所有事情，这种竞争和支配的驱动力。他把它想成某种东西，潜意识，像某种逻辑的东西。它只是与你的逻辑功能不一致。他把它想成某种自我激励的东西，想要某种东西，想要去某个地方。就像这是骑在你头上的另一个存在，试图通过关闭你身体里的东西并像拉动绳子来得到它想要的东西来打败你。就像这是一个试图劫持你大脑的搭车者。而且，那行不通，因为潜意识不是那样的，它是内隐反应，是的，它们确实表现为符号，而且有时这些东西确实有几乎隐喻或
allegorical component because like the voice of my abusive culture gets internalized as this thing that is dark and scary and it talks to me like this and I hear its voice and like yeah I mean those things happen but Freud was conceiving of it like there was this other logical being that was motivated towards an end that wanted all of these things that civilization and Victorian society didn't allow so because it was repressed it was like fighting back and to conceive of the unconscious in this way just makes it like another brain, another ego, another prefrontal cortex in a way that it just fundamentally is not. It's multiple assumptions that were useful to you throughout your life that you learned
寓言成分，因为就像我虐待文化的语言被内化为这种黑暗和可怕的东西，它这样对我说话，我听到了它的声音，是的，我的意思是这些事情确实发生了，但弗洛伊德把它构想为有另一个逻辑存在，它朝着一个目标前进，想要所有这些文明和维多利亚时代社会不允许的东西，所以因为它被压抑了，它就像在反击，而以这种方式构想潜意识只是让它像另一个大脑，另一个自我，另一个前额叶皮层，以一种它根本不是的方式。它是你在生活中一直觉得有用的多个假设，你学习了
because you thought you needed to survive that are so much information. And we need to develop not only a coherent language for self, but a coherent language for something like trauma and to understand the unconscious because that's what therapy is doing. Whether it's a stellate ganglion block, whether it's a ketamine drip, whether it's, you know, shamanic psilocybin, brain spotting, EMDR, long-term psychoanalysis where you get comfortable with another person. All of these things are breaking you into parts until you can feel these drives and
因为你认为你需要生存，那是如此多的信息。我们不仅需要为自我开发一种连贯的语言，还需要为像创伤这样的东西开发一种连贯的语言，并理解潜意识，因为这就是治疗正在做的事情。无论是星状神经节阻滞，无论是氯胺酮滴注，无论是，你知道，萨满裸盖菇素，脑点疗法，EMDR，长期精神分析，在那里你与另一个人变得舒适。所有这些事情都在把你分解成部分，直到你能感受到这些驱动力并
understand them. And you don't need to understand them intellectually. That's why psychoanalysis like hits a wall at a certain point. You can't. You have to experience them. And I think modern therapy is getting like much better at doing that. And I also think that my idea about there being different types of memory that need different types of therapy to unlearn the pathological reactions
理解它们。你不需要在智力上理解它们。这就是为什么精神分析在某一点上会撞墙。你不能。你必须体验它们。我认为现代疗法在做这件事方面变得好多了。而且我也认为我关于存在不同类型的记忆需要不同类型的疗法来消除它们所学习的病理反应的想法
that they learned, like isn't that original? Because all of the therapists that I've ever heard going back to the 70s, they seem to already be doing that logic in their head. They're just not thinking in the language that I'm thinking in. Pupillometry is an incredibly useful tool for this, and that's why you're going to see that explode. Looking at what the pupil is telling you that the brainstem is doing. We've used that in advertising for years to show somebody a shot of food porn for a McDonald's commercial or a movie trailer and then see what their eye was doing
并不那么原创。因为我听过的所有治疗师，追溯到70年代，他们似乎已经在脑子里做那种逻辑了。他们只是没有用我思考的语言在思考。瞳孔测量法是这方面一个非常有用的工具，这就是为什么你会看到它爆发。观察瞳孔告诉你脑干正在做什么。我们多年来在广告中使用它，向某人展示麦当劳广告或电影预告片的食物色情镜头，然后观察他们的眼睛在做什么
to see their emotional engagement. Because the pupil was more accurate at reporting what somebody would buy than they would, than they were at a debriefing or a cue card at the end of the thing, because your brain knows what it wants, you know? And, um, now you're starting to see like studies where they use, uh, you know, looking at the pupil to try and predict suicidality and things like that. And it makes sense because your pupil is dilating, you know, looking at the pupil to try and predict suicidality and things like that. And it makes sense because your pupil is dilating, you know, sometimes based on light, but also based on emotion in a way that you're not aware of and you can't control. So it's this,
以查看他们的情感参与度。因为瞳孔在报告某人会买什么方面比他们在事情结束时的汇报或提示卡更准确，因为你的大脑知道它想要什么，你知道？而且，嗯，现在你开始看到像研究这样的东西，他们使用，嗯，你知道，观察瞳孔来试图预测自杀倾向之类的事情。这是有道理的，因为你的瞳孔正在放大，你知道，观察瞳孔来试图预测自杀倾向之类的事情。这是有道理的，因为你的瞳孔正在放大，你知道，有时基于光，但也基于你没有意识到且无法控制的情绪。所以它是这个，
and there will be more, but like QEG, pupilometry, posture analysis, very intuitive people who can read muscle tension in physical therapy. Like those are all ways of knowing what the brainstem is doing before the person can. And so I think this two of those big points that we have to figure out if we're going to have like a consistent relevant therapy are how, what do we think the role of self is? Like what are our values as a society? And if it's ABA and CBTbt like i'm out okay i'm gonna go make way more money doing something else if we can have a sane conversation about how
而且会有更多，但像QEG、瞳孔测量法、姿势分析，在物理治疗中能读懂肌肉紧张的非常直觉的人。就像那些都是在人能够知道之前了解脑干正在做什么的方法。所以我认为如果我们想要像一致的相关疗法，我们必须弄清楚这两个大点，我们认为自我的作用是什么？就像我们作为一个社会的价值观是什么？如果它是ABA和CBT，好吧，我退出了，好吧，我要去赚更多的钱做别的事情，如果我们能就现代社会如何
modern society can conceive of the self as like'm talking about because they're not directly provable and they never will be is leaving us completely effing blind to how psychology works and what we need to do if we're going to fix trauma in our culture. But I also am not saying, like I think, like I said in the beginning, like I think that what that's doing is leaving us suffering without being able to scream. And if that's the goal of therapy, to help people not scream while they are suffering, again, I'm out. Okay? Like you want to take insurance, you want to take healthcare in that direction, I'm gone. But if you want to have the same conversation, like, I'm not saying that therapy needs to be spiritual, that we have to be woo-woo, that we have to, you know, go into this
构想自我进行理智的对话，就像我正在谈论的那样，因为它们不是直接可证明的，而且永远不会是，这让我们对心理学如何运作以及如果我们想修复我们文化中的创伤需要做什么完全视而不见。但我也不是说，就像我一开始说的那样，就像我认为那正在让我们在无法尖叫的情况下受苦。如果那是治疗的目标，帮助人们在受苦时不要尖叫，再说一次，我退出了。好吧？就像你想把保险，你想把医疗保健引向那个方向，我走了。但如果你想进行理智的对话，就像，我不是说治疗需要是精神上的，我们必须是神神叨叨的，我们必须，你知道，进入这个
place that is irrational. Because I think that a completely objective empiricism, you know, like, is setting you up for a psychology that doesn't work. But a complete, you know, spirituality, empty language, you know, going to people just because they're a hypnotic charismatic leader who can kind of live in the spiritual space and adopt like a a hypnotic felt sense of communication that's ripe for abuse and incredibly scary too what i'm saying is that you have to be able to understand the objective and the subjective as a therapist in order to research these things and like, and, and innovate. And that, you know, the Tuskegee experiments are just as bad as the Heaven's Gate cult. You know, like one is science and one is just complete hijacked, you know, mentally ill mysticism,
非理性的地方。因为我认为一个完全客观的经验主义，你知道，就像，是在为你设置一个不起作用的心理学。但一个完全的，你知道，灵性，空洞的语言，你知道，去寻找人们仅仅因为他们是一个催眠的魅力型领导者，可以某种程度上生活在精神空间并采用一种催眠的感受沟通，这很容易被滥用，而且也非常可怕。我所说的是，作为一名治疗师，你必须能够理解客观和主观，以便研究这些东西，并且，并且创新。而且，你知道，塔斯基吉实验和天堂之门邪教一样糟糕。你知道，就像一个是科学，一个是完全被劫持的，你知道，精神病式的神秘主义，
but neither one of them is good. Both of them are evil. You know, it, being able to sort through subjectivity and objectivity and when they're useful, I think is a huge goal to help people not be abused and to not fall prey to bad systems and also to understand themselves. And it's something that our culture is really bad at. Like we're trying to be hyper objective at the expense of our feelings and our intuitions, but those feelings and intuitions are driving us insane because we're trying to be so hyper-objective. And we have to kind of restore order to this. I think that when you look at how people want to retreat
但它们都不是好的。它们都是邪恶的。你知道，能够梳理主观性和客观性以及它们何时有用，我认为是一个巨大的目标，可以帮助人们不被虐待，不落入糟糕的系统，也了解他们自己。这是我们文化非常不擅长的事情。就像我们试图以牺牲我们的感受和直觉为代价变得过度客观，但那些感受和直觉正在让我们发疯，因为我们试图变得如此过度客观。我们必须某种程度上恢复这种秩序。我认为当你观察人们如何想要退缩
into like a subjective mystical realm and pretend that that can change objective reality, that's a problem, right? Like if you you have cancer you should go to the doctor i'm glad if you have a faith you can rely on i'm glad if you have spiritual practices that you do but you need some science there also and it is kind of delusional to pretend that and i know that things happen but to pretend that you know with certainty that this magic is going to make you better. You don't know. And sitting with the uncertain is one of the big tasks of adult life that we kind of talk around where the therapist says, oh yeah, yeah, I know that. And then you watch where they're
进入一个主观的神秘领域并假装那可以改变客观现实时，那是一个问题，对吧？就像如果你有癌症，你应该去看医生，如果你有你可以依赖的信仰，我很高兴，如果你有你做的精神练习，我很高兴，但你也需要一些科学，假装那有点妄想，我知道事情发生了，但假装你知道，确定这种魔法会让你好起来。你不知道。与不确定性共处是成年生活的大任务之一，我们某种程度上绕过了它，治疗师说，哦是的，是的，我知道那个。然后你观察他们自己在哪里
avoiding that anxiety themselves. Like in the same way, like science doesn't explain all of this. Tons of psychoeducation and behavioral programming, you know, leave you totally empty and still traumatized and with no sense of self and no idea who you are. You know, if there, and there are people who come to therapy that want that. Probably not people who listen to this podcast, but there are people who come in and they're like telling me, no, I want to come to you for like a year. And when I come in, I need you to do this thing where you just tell me that I did a good job on these things and a bad job on those things. And that makes me feel good and maybe give me a worksheet and I'll write it down and I'll come back. We'll do it again.
避免那种焦虑。就像同样的方式，就像科学并不能解释所有这些。大量的心理教育和行为编程，你知道，让你完全空虚，仍然受到创伤，没有自我感，也不知道你是谁。你知道，如果那里，有来治疗的人想要那个。可能不是听这个播客的人，但有人进来，他们就像告诉我，不，我想来找你一年。当我进来时，我需要你做这件事，你只是告诉我我在这些事情上做得很好，在那些事情上做得不好。这让我感觉很好，也许给我一张工作表，我会写下来，我会回来。我们会再做一次。
And they think that I'm like doing therapy wrong because I'm not doing what their CBT therapist did. And like, that leaves you not knowing who you are. That leaves you with no sense of self. Like we, we need both. And with implicit memory, like you're pushing somebody,
他们认为我做治疗做错了，因为我没有做他们的CBT治疗师做的事情。而且，那让你不知道你是谁。那让你没有自我感。就像我们，我们需要两者。而且对于内隐记忆，就像你在推动某人，
the therapist needs to be able to see things that you're avoiding where you're avoiding uncertainty. Maybe you're a hundred percent sure of who you are and morals and values. And like, you think, you know, because you get in fights about politics and you'll never let somebody tell you that art and magic like aren't the point of life and what you how you want to express yourself. But over here, you're deeply afraid of looking at the things that you could change to feel better and to make yourself happy in a way that you don't think you deserve.
治疗师需要能够看到你正在避免的事情，你在哪里避免不确定性。也许你百分之百确定你是谁以及道德和价值观。而且，就像，你认为，你知道，因为你为了政治而争吵，你永远不会让别人告诉你艺术和魔法就像不是生活的重点以及你如何想要表达自己。但在这一边，你非常害怕审视那些你可以改变以感觉更好并让自己快乐的事情，以一种你认为你不配得到的方式。
And the therapist has to see where you're not sitting with that uncertainty and push you into it. I don't care if it's like through analysis or brain spotting or whatever, but you need to be able to do that. And, and that is the thing that I see the industry sort of like crying out for, but also not saying. Um, so what I see as a better language is this idea of completing emotional arcs that what comes dysfunction you know when we say trauma i i don't like where like something like internal family systems makes me explain to a patient for 15 minutes the difference in a firefighter and a protector because most patients are like oh a protective part is a thing that flares up an implicit memory to make me not experience the thing that feels bad. And this one's very semantic and overwhelming. And this
治疗师必须看到你没有与那种不确定性共处的地方，并把你推向它。我不在乎它是通过分析还是脑点疗法还是其他什么，但你需要能够做到这一点。而且，那是我看到行业某种程度上在呼唤，但又没有说出来的东西。嗯，所以我认为更好的语言是完成情感弧线的想法，功能障碍，你知道，当我们说创伤时，我不喜欢像内部家庭系统（IFS）这样的东西让我向患者解释15分钟消防员和保护者之间的区别，因为大多数患者就像，哦，保护部分是那种在内隐记忆中爆发以使我不体验感觉糟糕的事情的东西。而这个非常语义化和压倒性。而这个
one's very like logical and almost has a personality structure to it. Like they just, they can get that without me trying to make them be taught like the semantics of IFS. I don't dislike IFS, but what is more useful to me is to say that all trauma is these series of emotional arcs that we're failing to complete. And I'm either enmeshed with the emotional arc where it's like, I'm not, I'm not angry. I'm not angry. What are you talking about? I'm not angry. Stop, stop. Or, you know, I'm not sad. There's nothing wrong. You know, clearly I'm feeling that emotion, but I don't know that because I'm feeling it all the time because the, the arc went up and it didn't come down or I'm avoiding the arc entirely. I'm just totally avoidant. And I'm like, no, no, no. Like, you know, I did something bad once. So don't,
非常逻辑化，几乎有一种人格结构。就像他们只是，他们可以得到那个，而不需要我试图让他们学习IFS的语义。我不讨厌IFS，但对我更有用的是说，所有的创伤都是这些我们未能完成的一系列情感弧线。我要么与情感弧线纠缠在一起，就像，我没有，我没有生气。我没有生气。你在说什么？我没有生气。停，停。或者，你知道，我不难过。没什么不对的。你知道，显然我感觉到了那种情绪，但我不知道，因为我一直感觉到它，因为弧线升上去了，它没有下来，或者我完全在避免那个弧线。我完全是回避型的。我就像，不，不，不。就像，你知道，我曾经做过坏事。所以不要，
don't say that that the thing she did is bad. Like, I know it just hurt us and that she keeps doing it and she always will, but I don't want to be judged for the time that I did a bad thing. So like, just don't say that. I don't have the authority to know that that, like, I'm not able to just be like, I'm angry. You don't have the right to talk to me like that. Nobody's perfect, but I'm going to objectively label the thing that you just did, that you continue to do and don't see as a problem. That's an avoidance of an emotional arc. And what brain spotting, what SLT, if you've come to taproot, QEG, these things, like they're pulling you through an emotional arc that you are either stuck in and is going on in your body all the time, or that you're avoiding entirely. And I think
不要说她做的事情很糟糕。我知道这伤害了我们，她一直在做，而且以后也会一直做，但我不想因为我曾经做过一件坏事而受到评判。所以，别那样说。我没有权力去断定，我无法仅仅表现得像是在说“我很生气，你没权利那样跟我说话”。没有人是完美的，但我会客观地指出你刚才做的事情，你一直在做且不认为那是问题的行为。那是在逃避情感弧线。而脑点疗法（Brainspotting）、SLT，如果你来过Taproot，或者QEG，这些东西都在引导你走过一段情感弧线，你要么被困在其中，它时刻在你的身体里发生，要么你完全在逃避它。我认为
that language of being pulled through the emotional arc is what's useful for me. I hope that it's useful for you. You know, one thing, there's the, I think you say her name, Baba, but I'm not positive. So don't, don't come for me. But the, the book from the nineties, the location of culture, you know, she wrote about how there was like a third space and it's been used in a lot of ways that I don't know there. She, she wrote about this book, uh, this idea of third space there where there's this kind of metaphorical, um, space, sometimes a physical space where there's different like mushiness to culture and identity and ideas, and they can come together and develop new meanings. And that being this sort of cultural locus where we could say, okay, we have to wear the persona of,
那种被引导走过情感弧线的语言对我很有用。我希望它对你也有用。你知道，有一件事，我想你读的是她的名字，巴巴（Baba），但我不太确定。所以别，别来找我麻烦。但是，那本九十年代的书《文化的定位》（The Location of Culture），你知道，她写了关于存在一种“第三空间”的内容，它被以很多我不知道的方式使用。她写了这本书，呃，关于第三空间的理念，那里有一种隐喻性的，嗯，空间，有时是物理空间，文化、身份和思想在那里有不同的融合，它们可以汇聚在一起并产生新的意义。这成为了一种文化场所，我们可以说，好吧，我们必须戴上某种面具，
you know, Christian or therapist or, you know, American or whatever all of our life. But when we go into these spaces, we can let that go down and we can all kind of merge together and we can learn from each other. Coming back to that quote that I read from the Michael Judge book in part one, this is very much about that kind of idea,
你知道，基督徒或治疗师，或者，你知道，美国人，或者我们生活中的所有角色。但当我们进入这些空间时，我们可以放下这些，我们可以融合在一起，互相学习。回到我在第一部分读到的迈克尔·贾奇（Michael Judge）书中的那段引语，这很大程度上就是关于那种理念，
that there's a hybridness to this, that the third spade is a site where the cultural elements kind of merge and create new hybrid forms of identity. Also, there's a liminality to it, but it's an in-between. You're kind of not anywhere. You've left the spheres of life, the home, the person, the church, the work, you know, the responsibility, and you're just in a place that has no context, but that lets you observe indirectly, more abstractly, and think creatively about all the context from the spheres of your life that you have to go into. Also, there's an idea of negotiation and transformation.
即这其中存在一种混合性，第三空间是一个文化元素融合并创造出新的混合身份形式的场所。此外，它还具有一种阈限性，它是一个中间地带。你仿佛身处虚无。你离开了生活的领域，家庭、个人、教会、工作，你知道，责任，你只是处于一个没有背景的地方，但这让你能够间接地、更抽象地观察，并创造性地思考你必须进入的生活领域中的所有背景。此外，还有一个关于协商和转化的理念。
That individuals go in and they negotiate and renegotiate their identity, either alone by looking at these spheres being outside of them or together communally. And then there's a transformation where interactions and exchanges occur. And all of a sudden norms, hierarchies and power structures that aren't needed can be discarded because we can get outside of them enough to not be controlled by them. And to me, if you want to look at what therapy should become, if it's not going to be taken over by the medical establishment, if it's going to be left in the realm of therapists. It needs to be something like that.
个体进入其中，他们协商并重新协商自己的身份，要么通过审视这些领域并置身其外来独自完成，要么共同完成。然后是转化，互动和交流发生。突然之间，那些不再需要的规范、等级制度和权力结构可以被抛弃，因为我们可以足够跳出它们，而不受其控制。对我来说，如果你想看看治疗应该变成什么样，如果它不被医疗机构接管，如果它被留在治疗师的领域内，它就需要是那样的东西。
The model needs to be something like that. I'm going to read a poem by William Gibson, who's one of the cyberpunk authors. He's the guy that wrote Neuromancer, if you're familiar. This is called Memory Palace. When we were only several hundred thousand years old, we built stone circles, water clocks. Later, someone forged an iron spring, set clockwork running, imagined gridlines on a globe. Cathedrals are like machines defining the soul.
这种模式需要是那样的。我要读一首威廉·吉布森（William Gibson）的诗，他是赛博朋克作家之一。如果你熟悉的话，他就是写《神经漫游者》（Neuromancer）的那个人。这首诗叫《记忆宫殿》（Memory Palace）。当我们只有几十万年历史时，我们建造了巨石阵、水钟。后来，有人锻造了铁弹簧，让发条运转，在地球仪上想象出网格线。大教堂就像定义灵魂的机器。
Bells of clock towers stitch the sleeper's dreams together. You see, so we've always been on our way to this new place That is no place really But it is real And it is our nature to represent We are the animal that represents The soul and only maker of maps And if our weakness has been to confuse the bright and bloody colors of our calendars With the true weather of days,
钟楼的钟声将沉睡者的梦缝合在一起。你看，所以我们一直在通往这个新地方的路上，那地方其实什么也不是，但它是真实的，代表事物是我们的天性。我们是代表事物的动物，是灵魂和地图的唯一制造者。如果我们的弱点一直是混淆了我们日历上明亮而血腥的颜色与日子真实的冷暖，
and the parchment's territory of our maps with the land spread out before us, never mind. We've always been on our way to this new place. That is no place, really. But it is real. That bright and bloody colors of our calendars with the true weather of days and the parchments territory of our maps with the actual land. We represent these things internally and we have to have science in order to represent them
以及混淆了我们地图上羊皮纸的领土与展现在我们面前的土地，没关系。我们一直在通往这个新地方的路上。那地方其实什么也不是，但它是真实的。那些日历上明亮而血腥的颜色与日子真实的冷暖，以及我们地图上羊皮纸的领土与实际的土地。我们在内部代表这些事物，我们必须拥有科学才能以这种方式客观地代表它们，
objectively in this way, but it becomes pathological when we think that the map is the land or that we think that the calendar is the day. It isn't. There's an ineffable quality to all this stuff that if we forget, we can't do science anymore because science is intimately connected to the thing that it is describing. And part of science will always be the limitations of our description. So, you know, I think the process of meaning making that I'm talking about, that takes a kind of science and a kind of spirituality, but not either back into therapy. I mean, we need that because we have this post-spiritual but also post-secular culture. I think therapists can be agents of that to hold the space that is outside of culture, outside of time, that makes room for things that we need to reflect on.
但当我们认为地图就是土地，或者认为日历就是日子时，它就变得病态了。事实并非如此。所有这些东西都有一种不可言说的特质，如果我们忘记了这一点，我们就无法再进行科学研究，因为科学与它所描述的事物紧密相连。科学的一部分永远是我们描述的局限性。所以，你知道，我认为我所谈论的意义构建过程，需要一种科学和一种灵性，但不是把两者带回治疗中。我的意思是，我们需要它，因为我们拥有这种后灵性但也是后世俗的文化。我认为治疗师可以成为其中的推动者，去保持那个处于文化之外、时间之外的空间，为我们需要反思的事情留出余地。
And that is kind of the future, hope of what we do because i think that if we do that what we're going to do is be able to see this idea of ourselves from the past before we were corrupted with trauma with all of the damage that happened where we were young kids and we just remembered something not Not remembered it, we just knew it. And then that thing is taken away from us. And therapy can take you back to that place that you always knew was there, that you always knew was you, that you always knew was this perspective that only you could do, but that we forget because we associate with all of these other things and we blend into them and we lose the self. And if therapy is not taking you back in time, back to this thing that you can remember,
这就是我们所做之事的未来和希望，因为我认为如果我们这样做，我们将能够看到我们过去的样子，在我们被创伤腐蚀之前，在我们年轻时发生的所有伤害之前，那时我们只是记得某件事，不是“记得”，我们只是“知道”它。然后那个东西被从我们身边夺走了。治疗可以带你回到那个你一直知道它存在的地方，你一直知道那是你，你一直知道那是只有你能拥有的视角，但我们忘记了，因为我们与所有这些其他事物联系在一起，我们融入了它们，我们失去了自我。如果治疗不能带你回到过去，回到这个你可以记住，
but you've forgotten, then you're not really dealing with a conception of self that I can get down with. And at the same time, it can help you figure out how you bring that into a world that is objective and material and kind of cruel and doesn't care about you in a material sense. How you can make the compromises to take that inner self and then bring it into expression through the limitations of things like time and finances and emotions and the culture that you're in and the other people who are around you. And that is a messy process that we need help with. And it is a process that I am starting to see, you know, come back to therapy. But this is my attempt to describe what it sounds like the people that I'm listening to
但你已经忘记的东西，那么你并没有真正处理我所能接受的自我概念。同时，它可以帮助你弄清楚如何将那个自我带入一个客观、物质、有点残酷且在物质意义上不在乎你的世界。你如何做出妥协，将那个内在自我带入现实，并通过时间、财务、情感以及你所处的文化和你周围的其他人的局限性来表达它。这是一个混乱的过程，我们需要帮助。这是一个我开始看到，你知道，回到治疗中的过程。但这只是我试图描述我所倾听的人们听起来想要什么，
are saying that they want. And in that way, you know, psychotherapy itself is kind of a simulacra because it is, you know, leading you someplace that is no place really. It's trying to make a copy of something in the future, in the past that don't exist, you know, where our intuitive knowledge remained uncorrupted and unforgotten and it's pure and in totality. And there's also the self that we can bring into fulfillment. And I think that, you know, for humans there's two pretty big inevitabilities. And one of them is pain. We will hurt each other.
他们所说的话。从这个意义上说，你知道，心理治疗本身就是一种拟像（simulacra），因为它，你知道，把你引向一个其实什么也不是的地方。它试图在未来或过去制造某种不存在的东西的副本，你知道，在那里我们的直觉知识保持着未被腐蚀和未被遗忘的状态，它是纯粹且完整的。还有一个我们可以实现自我满足的自我。我认为，你知道，对于人类来说，有两个相当大的必然性。其中之一是痛苦。我们会互相伤害。
Whether or not we mean to. So much of our behavior goes into either trying to hurt people because we're hurt or not hurt anybody because we're hurt. You know, it's a pretty big motivator. And it's not one that is ever going to be eradicated or go away. And the other one is love, that we have this ability to, despite pain, connect and forgive and be. And the hurting is inevitable, but the loving is not.
无论我们是否有意。我们的许多行为要么是因为我们受了伤而试图伤害别人，要么是因为我们受了伤而不想伤害任何人。你知道，这是一个很大的驱动力。它永远不会被根除或消失。另一个是爱，我们有这种能力，尽管有痛苦，依然能够连接、宽恕和存在。伤害是不可避免的，但爱不是。
And I hope that we remember how to love because we're not gonna forget how to hurt. Thanks for watching! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我希望我们记得如何去爱，因为我们不会忘记如何去伤害。感谢观看！本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。